so I'd like to talk about building and
deploying scalable intelligent systems
by 2025 and first thing I do is I need
your help because the acoustics of this
room etc I need somebody in front to
please volunteer to repeat questions
from the audience
anybody will need to volunteer to do
that yeah so these summit meetings the
audience will ask a question and your
job should you choose to accept it is to
repeat the question
ah because then the acoustics are
something that I will be then I will
pick it up from you or a Noblet that's
right very good thank you very much Andy
okay so let's try it question it's hard
to get people to do that Oh repeat the
question please
that's right
and people would people would like to do
that no no no coercion right but if
you'd like to do that fine yeah come
it'll be it'll it'll be more friendly
that way thank you Kroc
and it's a perfectly okay to look back
in the corner if you want to no problem
yeah yay yeah Martin okay so talk about
scalable intelligent applicant no it
should be saleable intelligent systems
this is a leftover slide from days of
yours originally this this presentation
is fairly old but should say scalable
intelligent systems and they have three
very important aspects massive
information pervasive inconsistency and
human collaboration and so why do we
have these three aspects well let's take
a look at a kind of typical problem of
an intelligent system so we are very
much interested in pain management and
of course everybody knows the classic
problem pain and management is a opioid
addiction so addiction is a very complex
problem
it's an enormous industry and it comes
in a variety of forms there's opioid
addiction which is associated with pain
management there's sugar addiction which
is an enormous problem for our society
not yet on the a bit on the very bad
list and then there's adrenaline
addiction at work work is the favorite
addiction of Silicon Valley causes an
enormous amount of harm and addiction it
has a kind of cycle you go through where
you get your high right
and then you go through a crash and then
you get the craving and it goes back up
to relapse okay and once again you know
you get yeah you go back for the high
and around around you just circle the
drain until a very small percentage of
the case you get into some kind of
recovery
or you know it kills you that's the
cycle and it's based on things like fear
shame and anger there's a there's a
whole whole literature on this so what
can we do mmm well it's very complicated
problem the idea is that if you were to
come back here in seven to ten years
almost every the idea is that ever
almost everybody in this room would be
wearing halle glasses now some of you
will say not me it was like my partner
for a long time she said not me for the
for the for the cellphone right and but
now you know she's just as addicted
halted all the rest that just totally
dependent on it right and the deal is
that this is completely terrible from a
human factors point of view me trying to
talk to you and do this is just and for
one thing I have to keep glancing down
and glancing up right and the other
thing this is a very tiny little
periscope and for another thing after I
do this for a while my hand wants to
fall off okay so the idea is you just
leave it in your pocket right and you
wear the glasses and the minimal Viable
Product for hala glasses is that you can
leave your phone in your pocket and
everything you currently do on your
phone you can do with these glasses that
is the criteria for a big player
shipping and since then since we already
have you know kind of prototypes and
examples from startups that already can
do most of it it's for sure that one of
the big players are going to do it an
Apple as a
business proposition has to do it
because they make their money selling
devices as opposed to the advertising
surveillance ecosystem the way that
other companies like Facebook make their
money so Apple needs to do it and they
need to do it extremely well because
they're very dependent on getting that
initial market share so they're hard at
work right
they made the hires they've done the
acquisitions they filed the patents
right
and they're working with as much secrecy
as they can possibly muster because as
and as was the case with the phone the
secret sauce is in the user interface
and with the billion dollar secret is
the user interface but we know a few
things we know that the people that had
this theory I'm gonna use my hollow
glasses like this yeah that won't fly
and also it can't be entirely
voice-based
because otherwise I can't use my hollow
glasses while I'm talking to you face to
face so there is some secret sauce there
in the case of the the cellphone the
secret sauce was unlike all the previous
phones that I used where I had to pull
out a little chunk of plastic and use
that to write on the screen right Mike
come on on the screen that way instead
you just use your finger and that turned
out to be the trick that pushed it over
and made it into a mass device so there
has to be similar kind of trickery for
the holidays in order for them to gain
mass adoption but once you start to hat
once you have the devices okay then it
becomes like that the problem we had was
with the personal computers right we
could make the PCs but then you have to
develop a whole new class of software
because the mainframe software just
wasn't going to do it for you so we had
to invent word and we had to vote which
actually came out of Bravo and we had to
invent PowerPoint and we had to invent
all these things we did on the PCs and
then the PC all those things pretty much
transferred straight over to our cell
phones because it's just a PC in your
pocket so the same things gonna have to
happen with these glasses a whole new
class of applications it's going to have
to be developed and we're looking at
pain management as one of these kinds of
things where you can make intelligent
systems so what can we do for people in
pain besides giving them opioids for one
thing a sense of kind of sense of
community can really help it turns out
people in pain in woods if grandma or
grandpas in pain being able to interact
you know in a reasonable way with a
grandchild okay or with their doctor or
with the medical practitioners actually
helps these kinds of devices can well be
much much better than that our current
phones are and helping us with exercise
but you can actually watch what you're
doing see what you're doing
terms you your physical therapy and your
exercise it can watch what you're eating
so it can help you with the nutrition
and so they're going to be much more
intimate devices and all of that can
help with pain management and then
there's this thing called spirituality
it can help you with meditation it can
provide you with soothing music it can
help you with hypnosis which is actually
a medical treatment for pain there's a
practitioner over here in the medical
school I can introduce you to they've
shown in a medical study if you believe
in medical studies how hypnosis can help
manage pain
and then there's entertainment if you
get entertained then all sudden your
pain doesn't seem to be so bad and then
there's managed medication you know it
can watch you take your pills
so it's a study and instead of trying to
find some kind of surgery or some new
kind of pill to do pain management which
are the traditional answers that we've
gotten from medicine right there is an
you set up this ecosystem to manage pain
is the idea and we'll see it takes a lot
of investment it's gonna take a lot of
software it's gonna be complex but
nobody has a better idea nobody's come
up with the surgery nobody's the pills
aren't working out so well the opioids
aren't working out so well they are
necessary in certain cases if you have a
battlefield injury or somebody who's
just had you know severe surgery hope
you might be appropriate for a period of
time and also if you have a terminal
cancer patient right opioids might be
appropriate for a long term term use so
that is the class of intelligent system
that we are interested in addressing in
kind of the 2025 timeframe as opposed to
toy problems like games like go which
are intellectually challenging for
humans but not the kind of thing that
we're going for so this gives rise to a
considerable amount of complexity namely
it looks like it takes a whole
technology stack to to do this and I'm
going to be talking about these various
levels from the sort of hardware all the
way back to down to the bottom the kind
of services that we currently have now
onto how we're gonna have to create
massive and consistency robust ontology
's
and then put natural language on top of
that and then do experiences with
collaborations gestures and video on top
of that and then we have these things
called Citadel's
which offer no single point of failure
and fit with a kind of way that the
hardware and the software is evolving in
order to provide security and latency
and performance but this is the most
complex software that has ever been
undertaken by a longshot
this is more complicated than the space
program than anything else that we would
have attempted so how to get it done now
there's some parts of it you can kind of
peel off like hollow glasses there'll be
many companies that make can make Holly
glasses if they're capitalized
sufficiently for example Samsung and LG
and Facebook and a few other companies
can actually make Holly glasses it turns
out it's not trivial to make Hoffman
glasses really not trivial now you can
make the the homebrew Computer Club
version of holo glasses and like meta
has already gone Bally out the Train and
we have a magic leap which has produced
the bug-eyed version but that's not the
real thing that's not the thing kind of
thing that Apple is going to ship in a
very few years they have to be
lightweight they will be mostly battery
because you want them to last all day
gonna be very little in the holo glasses
other than the stuff for the i/o
everything else will be in your opinion
in the phone in your pocket and they'll
be communicating wirelessly with that so
that is the complexity and the
technology stack that were look
mm-hmm so there's some history
we've had some notable failures in doing
large software projects IBM did the FS
project futures system project which was
going to be the successor to the 360
which they spend enormous amount of
money I actually consulted on that one
what a monster that was and it was a
miserable flop they could not make that
thing go there was a there was there was
a system that finally came out of it
right that was shipped as a kind of
departmental machine but it wait it has
to be counted as a colossal failure and
then there was the Itanium nicknamed I
tannic which was an attempt by HP and
Intel to do a successor to the x86
architecture and they bet on the wrong
horse it turned out because they wanted
to try to own the whole horse intel had
a problem they had that they they had to
they were forced to license lots of the
x86 patents to amee so this this was a
horse they were going to own all by
themselves well they owned the horse how
are that's like heavy stock in a startup
right maybe not worth anything at all
and this one didn't work and then there
was I caught the Japanese
fifth-generation project which was an
attempt on the part of me T the Ministry
of International Trade industry in Japan
to leapfrog IBM what had happened is
Japan had done very well in the DRAM
market they have completely out space
need be the United States in terms of
cost of production and in terms of the
quality of their products they had taken
over the whole thing now they had the
DRAM market so what was next was the
computer industry of course except they
were kind of becoming sensitive to being
accused of being copycats so they said
well let's leap frogged IBM and go for
something you know in terms of guarded
horn clauses right there's this horn
clause thing which came from from the UK
which was based on basically a subset of
a system called planner that I did for
my thesis and they thought that that
would be the way to go because there
would there would be parallelism and it
was you know it was supposed to be used
for artificial intelligence and so what
could possibly go wrong and the thing
that did them in was was was an
invention by a friend of mine Ola Johann
Dahl who do it was who was the compiler
writer for a system called Simula what
was it which was at the beginning of
object-oriented programming and so he
worked with another friend of mine
Kristin Nygaard they invented they did
Simula simulated 737 off of it called
methods and you might think it would be
expensive to call a procedure way out
here on the fringes of the tree but all
on jahaan invented this thing called the
tables which enabled you to call a
procedure even if it's out in the edge
of the tree just as fast as a basically
an ordinary procedure calls basically
index jump so we were doing
object-oriented programming we had fast
procedure calls icon was doing this
pattern direct invocation thing they had
slow procedure calls and they could not
compete so those are some classic large
projects that didn't make it and they
nowhere near the complexity of what we
need to do for these intelligent systems
so now we're in the midst of the deep
bubble
and the deep bubble is based on these
deep correlation classifiers of the kind
that we've come to knowing use and they
have been very successful in providing
the economic foundation the valley in
terms of the advertising surveillance
ecosystem that in competing with
ordinary throw it over the wall
advertising where the advertisers your
basic pumps in the money and pray is
right that maybe they'll get some sales
they actually have an interactive
clickbait system right that actually
goes caching and makes them an enormous
amount of money so this is the first
time where artificial intelligence has
really made a large amount of money so
of course what do we do we over
generalize and say well let's do
everything that way but the problem is
that it's not clear how you get deep
tree classifiers to do this and in
particular there are a whole bunch of
pieces of this technology stack which is
also very difficult to see how you're
going to get you know deep tree
classifiers just to solve that problem
it's just totally unclear so our recipe
for success is as they say fail fail
again and now our challenge is to fail
better so let's dig in to this
technology stack in particular let's
look at the actor services thing right
the software and here there are things
called
actors and actors are the universal
primitives and concurrent computation
when an actor receives a communication
it can currently send communications to
the unfortunate addresses of other
actors that it has create new actors and
how to handle the next message it
receives this is very much like
object-oriented programming except that
we have to do it with efficiently with a
massive amount of concurrency and we
have to do it securely and right now the
current systems we have don't do the
concurrency very well and they're really
lacking in security so let's take a
simple example of an actor here's an
actor
it's a readers writers scheduler so this
is a classic computer science probably
find it in all the textbooks and the
idea is you've got a database and it's
an old-style database and so it can only
if there's a writer in the database you
can't have any other writers and you
can't have a reader so what we want to
do is put a scheduler in front of this
database that schedules access to our
old-style database that has this
constraint so we're gonna create a
scheduler and there are two kinds of
messages that come in there read
messages and write messages and we're
standing in front of the database so
we're just transparently scheduling
these these going through so when a a
read message comes in the nume there
might be a writer in the database so you
might have to go into a readers queue so
you go to the readers queue then finally
when it's when it's ok then you send the
resource the right message with the
query that you got passing through the
reading crowd and then when you come out
you return the thing that you got from
the database back so basically you're
transparently sitting in front of this
database doing the scheduling so the way
that's implemented as an actor is all
the actors kind of look the same right
turns out they have a manager ok and
then they have facets
so the the here's the here's the manager
the facets are the thing that's going to
do the read and the write right and the
manager is the thing that takes care of
all the coordination of the shared State
among the facets so one of the things
that's different about our brave new
world is this scalable intelligence
system is not allowed to go down okay
it's like a Google search or the
electricity or art or are these at least
these things it's not allowed to go down
okay but it needs to be able to be
upgraded so for the men so you have you
have this thing here and for the manager
you can ask it for its scheduler or you
can ask it to upgrade itself to a new
version of itself and the same time it
has this facet down here for the reads
and the rights so it implements two
different interfaces one from the
manager which is the readers writers
manager and the other one for the actual
forwarding stuff through to the database
so here's what the manager looks like he
says okay I'm a read priority manager
right I take a database as a parameter
right and then I have some variables
namely I have two queues a writers queue
to readers queue and to crowds called
writing and reading the writers queue
and readers queue or where readers and
writers wait while they're before
they're going to the database and the
two crowds writing they're reading okay
hold if the whole if reading the reading
crowd will hold you know whoever it is
that's reading in the database and the
writing look holds hopefully only one
who's writing in the database so if if
if if somebody asks us to upgrade
ourselves to a new version upgrade to a
new version then we have to cancel all
the activities and the readers to you
the writers queue the reading and
writing and become the
version so in this way the thing can
keep going right at the cost of
canceling some activities and this is a
world that's like android on any
instruction you can be blown away
program accordingly okay
so this requires a certain amount or
overall bus Ness encoding these
intelligent applications with the
thought that at any time you can be
blown away but that's just life and one
reason for that is it turns out that
these these things are going to be
implement on much on multiple machines
that are communicating with each other
and one of your companion machines might
go away or become incommunicado at any
time and you have to be able to deal
with that so the next thing is the
scheduler and here's a whole bunch of
logic we can come back to it at the end
but it basically has to do with the in
queueing and the crowds and the
scheduling all the details but let's
just go through one moves that says says
if I get a require that I in queue in
the readers queue when do I do that when
when when when writing or writers queue
or readers queue is not empty then I
actually pass it through to the database
passing through the reading crowd okay
and then after I come out I permit the
readers queue so this is a this is a
readers priority scheduling so if a
reader goes in ok well then when it
comes out if there's another reader in
the readers queue it lets it in so
you're gonna let all these readers go in
together provided own writers so there's
a little bit of logic here if you want
to during the question answering period
we can go through that but that's not
really a very important what is
important is that this is the way you
make scaleable actors you provide the
actor with a manager the manager has the
shared state of the facets
and you implement a number of facets to
provide the various kinds of
functionality that this actor kata needs
to implement and that's the general
pattern of how you implement an actor
now there's a some differences here it's
not exactly the same as object-oriented
programming because you only have reuse
instead of inheritance
the problem with inheritance is that if
some class inherits us from you it can
impersonate you which is a huge security
risk you don't want that so instead each
implementation says you know III indeed
my implementation say I use this I use
this I use this and nobody inherits from
me and you need that because you don't
want people to be copying and pasting
code you'd like to explicitly say I
reuse I use that I use that I use that
as opposed to going out and in your text
editor copying that and pasting it into
your code because you completely lose
track of what depends on what and you
can't maintain it when you clean it
changes out there it wouldn't change
here so that's a difference and then
there's this principle of an induction
that applies to all the actors which
says that if you have some proper
predicate P okay if P is true when X is
created and if P is true when X receives
a communication then it's true after it
processes the communication then it's
always the case that P holds for active
effort for that that property holds for
that actor so that is the general
inductive principle it's very much like
the principle
duction for integers if it holds for
zero and if it holds for I then it holds
for I plus one then it always than it
always holds and that applies here
because we can show in the case of our
scheduler here that there's an invariant
that holds namely if writing the writing
crowd is not empty then the reading
crowd is empty so if you have a writer
in the database then you're not reading
so that those are the basic building
blocks out of which these things are
going to be made and now we'll take a
look at the next level down the many
actor cores it turns out that we are
going to need zillions of these actors
so to make zillions of them we're going
to need thousands of general-purpose
cores on a chip and these cores have to
be small they have to be fast and they
have to be low powered and what is fast
being it's not just you know sequential
performance fast means that on a chip if
you have an actor here and active there
on the average the amount of latency
between sending a message and a
receiving a message between actors has
to average to be about 10 nanoseconds
now 10 nanoseconds is not very long and
current systems that we currently have
like in Java no way meet that goal but
that's where we need to get in order to
make these scalable scalable intelligent
systems so that's a large engineering
challenge and that means that you know
an actor on one side of the chip cannot
be spent and sending very many messages
to actors on the other side of the chip
or you're not going to meet that 10
nanosec
average budget no way so you have to
have extreme locality and message
passing and then for security you need
to have every word tagged we've known
this ever since the list machine and
what that does is it keeps the current
stupid tricks that the hacker is
plotting that the attackers play on us
like buffer overruns or forging return
pointers or all the other stupid tricks
they play on us makes it impossible
because the hardware prevents it and we
need to do the crypto securely that
means we need to put the crypto in a
Faraday cage on chip so there can't be
any side channel attacks on the crypto
and there can't be any way to steal to
spy on the encryption of the decryption
and there's no way to steal the secret
keys in fact what you do is you generate
a public key private key pair inside the
Faraday cage and the private key never
leaves the Faraday cage so the private
key is never seen by any piece of
software and never seen by any human it
is literally cannot be stolen so that's
the kind of hardware base that it's
going to take to do this
so back to our complexity so what's now
we've taken a look at the actor services
that searched the doctor service of the
traditional stuff that's where all of
our current software systems basically
lives at the actor system that in
addition to garbage collection okay then
we need some innovation in Hardware
below that level now comes a really
difficult part and that is someplace to
integrate all of this information is
massive and it's inconsistent so how is
that to be done well we take our
inspiration from Juan Moreau
anybody who knows who won Moreau was yes
I actually have one of his guavas and
bought the back when they were cheap
enough that you could afford to buy
their marvelous it look it up on the
Wikipedia I mean he had a marvelous
sense of humor which will serve us well
in our enterprise here but it's an
acronym for a massive inconsistency
robust ontology and the idea is we are
going to put all the information in
tomorrow into the psychology all the
information goes in there so let's first
of all take a look at propositional
information the traditional thing and
we'll take as an example the art of war
a traditional example from from China
and in the art of war there are various
kinds of prescriptions about how to
conduct the art of art for the generals
the strategy of the tactics so here it
says when the goal is to Bluff the
opponents of X and we have an assertion
that X is weak that set the goal for X
to appear strong on the other hand when
the goal is to Bluff the opponents of X
when you have the assertion that X is
strong then set the goal
to appeal to appear weak so what's
happened is that the previous kind of
low-level object-oriented programming is
too now too low too low-level for us to
be able to deal effectively with these
intelligent systems we need to rise to a
higher level to something called logic
programs so don't get scared it's just
message Cassie it says that when you
have a message that comes in that says
the goal is to Bluff the opponents of X
okay so the hope is that this can be
taught to programmers and they can
understand and debug these things
without too much trouble
remains to be seen it's going to be a
speed bump
just as going from Fortran to
object-oriented programming was a
significant speed bump for many
programmers as you will recall so we got
another one coming up here now here we
have an additional complication that we
have multiple overlapping goals so when
the goal is to intimidate that
intimidate the opponents of X then set
the goal to appear strong on the other
hand when the goal is to block the
opponents of X and the assertion is that
X is strong then set the goal to appear
weak you can begin to see that we're
starting to maybe get ourselves into an
interesting situation because if you
appear strong then you do not appear
weak and if you appear weak then you do
not appear strong and so now we can end
up with a situation in which we have
in consistent goals so in the goal to
intimidate the opponents of the blue
army a goal to bluff the opponents in
the bull army an assertion that the blue
army is strong therefore from one we got
the goal to appear strong before the
blue army to appear strong and from two
and three we now have the goal for the
blue army to appear weak and that turns
in to inconsistent goals well in
classical logic if you have a single
inconsistency it detonates the system
and you can conclude everything so what
to do about that well what you do about
that is you say well that's great for
classical mathematics but we're gonna
have something new called
inconsistency robustness and the idea is
we're going to have a reasoning system a
logic a system in which you can reason
about inconsistent information and not
have it blow up at the same time this
system needs to be reasonably intuitive
you've got to be able to explain this to
ordinary programmers and it's got to
make sense and hang together so that has
been a very long task starting with a
polish guide named Geoff's Kowski way
back in the 30s just Kowski Oh
[Music]
and there's one of these things is a
polish letter I forgotten which one but
anyway he started he started this off
way back in the 30s and his idea was
basically filtration what we'll do is
we'll take classical logic and the rules
that cause trouble will just throw them
out and we'll just we'll just keep the
rest and it's pretty frustrating because
particularly for us because when we make
these intelligent systems like pain
management we can't get the computer to
do the whole job humans are an integral
part of a pain management system so that
means that humans have got to be able to
communicate with the computers the
computers have got to be the communicate
for the humans they have to be mutually
intelligible so how do we come to terms
with how can the community the Machine
maintain its sanity not enable the
hackers to attack it and still
communicate with the humans for example
there's something called excluded middle
P or not P right which is often used in
common sense reasoning so but if you
allow P or not P it's easy to show that
the system blows up right one of my
students here cow actually showed that
as part of his graduate research that
causes systems blow up so we just can't
allow that that's a plane in vanilla so
what we do is we put in a speed bump the
Machine says okay you want SCI or not
SCI P or not P right
you can have that provided you can show
that syas not a contradiction if you can
show that it is not the case you have
tsiyon not sigh then we will let you
have excluded middle so this introduces
a point of negotiation between the
humans and the computers about what's
going on the computer system says yeah
but have you considered whether or not
Sai is a contradiction if I get a
dialogue going on back and forth instead
of the Nancy Reagan just say no
philosophy okay which was what pair
consistent logic as it's called started
by Geoff's Kowski did as we say okay
let's have a discussion because we got a
lot of humans into this so this this
little thing here where you said well
you said the thing on the left hand side
of the turnstile saw a not sie are not
side that is a speed bump that the
computer puts in to prevent it from
being exploited and as a point of
discussion with the humans involved in
the thing because the human wants to use
excluded middle and we don't we don't
want to say just say no right and
there's another one even proof proof by
contradiction proof by contradiction is
often used in common sense reasoning
right and what that says it is that if
from from fee you can you can infer a
sigh and not sigh look you can infer in
contradiction that means you have not
fee if you assume something you derive a
contradiction then that means that your
assumption doesn't hold so again we put
in a speed bump we said that's fine but
we'd really like to have some connection
between sigh and fee beyond just
deriving a contradiction because we've
got contradictions you know lying around
everywhere inside the ontology they're
just a dime a dozen so you put in the
speed bump that psy has to infer not fee
and not psy has to infer not
as points of discussion with human
arrays it wouldn't say hey look what do
you think about this again turning it
into a dialogue so this is the general
kind of approach for scalable
intelligent systems and you got to get
the humans involved and you want to have
a discussion and you want to keep it to
keep out the hackers and the attackers
and you don't want to you don't want to
lay it out arbitrary rules against the
humans so that is the general approach
here on how to deal with all of these
tremendous number of inconsistencies and
it being an ontology right we have this
this hard tangled hierarchy of things
that do inherit from one another so we
also have these in addition to these
propositions we have descriptions right
the famous you know John is a man a man
is immortal therefore John is immortal
so again we go back to the art of war so
here we have some something that's a
bluffer and we is in the cut is in the
description appears strong something
that's bluffer and strong is in appears
weak and again we have multiple
overlapping descriptions so we have an
Intimidator is in as an opponent that
has appearance strong and a bluffer and
an opponent that has appearance strong
is is in an opponent that has appearance
weak so in addition to constructing the
propositional side of the world for our
ontology we also have to describe a can
do the the descriptive side and then you
have opposite description and once once
again an opponent that has strength
strong is not in this is in the
complement of an opponent that has
strength weak an opponent that has
strength weak is in the complim
as an opponent has strength strong and
again we have inconsistent descriptions
and we use the same kind of tactics for
dealing with inconsistent descriptions
that we use for dealing with
inconsistent propositions so that is the
general approach for how to do this and
we're gonna see how well it works out in
practice so what about statistical info
information we've got a lot of that and
again we can't just say throw it out or
don't use it it's it's valuable right in
fact somebody some people have made a
religion out of it the date they think
that the data is King right well
sometimes the data is not King right
sometimes the theory is king bike for
example is the famous Michelson Morley
experiment where well actually that was
the case where the data was King the
data actually defeated the previous
theory and supported supported the new
theories and never mind that okay but we
do want to incorporate all of this
statistical information but but have to
do this with some degree of
sophistication because it turns out to
be alarmingly easy to hack these deep
correlation classifiers and here's a
famous example the thing on the left is
is it's the original image and it's it's
classified as 98% confident 95 percent
confidence that it's a cat the thing on
the right looks kind of similar 98%
confidence that it's a toaster so it has
been hacked but this is this is this is
quite alarming because given we have
humans involved in this how do we
explain to a human that this has been
classified as a toast
that very curious why we don't know why
and how to debug it we don't know how to
debug it so that's not so good and then
again then it started getting worse
what's the hackers who gets get get
going they really get going
so here we have some other interesting
examples here we have the less bottom
one you can see this very well left most
image is a bus with certainty but the
thing the next picture over is sort of
the underside of a bus and that's 0.99 a
garbage truck and the tilted bus is
certainly a punching bag
and the bus on this what tells it that
was crossed your side of the road that
is 0.92 a snowplow we're in trouble my
friends okay down here we have take the
one bottom firetruck leftmost 0.99 but
if you see if he can see if he's come
off the road here then he's a school bus
point nine two nine eight if he's up if
he's upside down fire boy fire boat 0.98
and this guy who's totally upside down
on the road is a bobsled 0.79 now the
thing is that we just created these
classifiers and we put in a database of
images and we train them up on those
images and we don't know how these image
classifiers work what could possibly go
wrong
well then it got worse people figured
out how to make robust adversarial
examples so they actually made a turtle
3d printed a turtle
as an adversarial turtle doesn't look
for yet espero
but it's very little reliably classified
as a rifle this is not good from every
viewpoint it looks like a rifle to the
classifier so we're in trouble why are
we in trouble the reason that we're in
trouble is we have a profound failure to
communicate the deep correlation
classifiers don't understand concepts in
any way shape or form and what is it
they're lacking they're lacking in
modularity they're sort of take the
thing as a whole there's no independent
modules inside the thing and it doesn't
provide any kind of argument eight
argumentation based on evidence but
nevertheless we'd like to have these
classifiers they can be useful and you
could take results with a grain of salt
so the proposal is to put the
correlation classifiers into the massive
inconsistent robust ontology to train
them up concurrently to monitor the
results and debug them against one
another so sure you don't say no to the
classifiers you say come on we'll take
you we'll put you in the ontology we'll
have you no problem we'll incorporate
you you're fine so famously said embrace
and extend so that's the idea is this is
to incorporate them and put them into
the ontology and then we're left with
Moreau having propositional info
descriptive info narrative info -
statistical info all these kinds of
information
and we have some we have some some some
some experience with that and in
medicine we have the protégé system over
here we can't do inconsistent
inconsistent but you know people put a
large amount of medical information
ontology z' into protégé and are getting
good value out of them so we have some
experience we're not totally without
experience and now the challenge is to
take it to the next generation and to
run really massive ones based on actors
zillions and zillions of actors sending
messages back and forth to one another
in an inconsistency robust way this is
the engineering challenge are we up for
it stay tuned so now I'd like to take a
look at another level of the hierarchy
namely the Citadel's and the Citadel's
are basically security units of people
and their IOT devices so in particular I
like to look at military Citadel's and
citizen Citadel's
you know military Citadel's are very
important because military is taking a
look at it the United States military
has become tremendously dependent on the
data centers back in the u.s. just
enormous ly because you know the people
we were fighting like Saddam Hussein you
know or Isis they couldn't do anything
about that they were just totally
helpless the opponents were gonna face
in the future are not so helpless
they've already demonstrated
anti-satellite capabilities faith
infamously right they sent up an
anti-satellite they destroyed one of the
satellites they created enormous amount
of debris we told him not to do it again
but they demonstrated that they can do
it
so the guys out in the field realized
now that each one of these military
units is going to have to be prepared to
in terms of information infrastructure
to float its own boat that communication
back to to the central headquarters can
be intermittent and it can sometimes be
very low bandwidth so that can't be part
of the standard operational plan so we
need a new architecture of moving
computing to the edge and not only that
but you have a latency issue
particularly with a holo glasses right
well you're you're looking at ten
microcytic and kind of latencies in
order to respond effectively and some of
the other were the reactions that you're
doing with somebody with their holo
glasses ten milliseconds and you can't
do ten milliseconds back to the data
center and back to you it just cannot be
done and the militaries are already
starting to testing these Holly glasses
right they bought the early prototypes
the US Army's bought some early
prototypes the Holly glasses aren't
there yet but the military's are already
starting to gain early experience and
they are that the soldier of the future
well like everybody else be wearing
hollar glasses and that's just the
nature of the thing nature of the beast
and so it's going to be part of the
future Silicon Valley to work on these
kinds of things right in an appropriate
way with a military right so we have
some challenges within some of the
companies some people don't like to work
with the military but at the same time
you know every country needs to have a
competent military force it cannot be
that the other guys have Holly glasses
okay and can run circles around you
that's that I have a military at all
right
so you want to have a competent military
and you need your technology industry to
support that so we need to work this out
in some kind of ethical reasonable way
it's going to be a real challenge and
then there are the citizens cell
Citadel's and the idea is each family
has its own Citadel so here we have a
home right Citadel right and we've got
the the TV and in person with the holy
glasses right and the home router and
the car right and that ideally is a
defensible unit in and of itself even
though it runs on multiple devices it
needs to have a kind of coherent idea
what's going on and you need to be able
to lose any one of these without losing
your Citadel which means the Citadel has
to run distributed amongst your glasses
your router your car your TV and that is
another huge engineering challenge to do
that and at the same time of course
you'd like to back this information up
into some kind of data center someplace
but you'd like to encrypt it with your
public key so only you can get it back
and read it now we need a business model
for this or it's never going to happen
the only business model has ever worked
on the net is free free of course is not
free right you're not paying for it okay
you're not the customer you're the
product that's being sold and diced
right maybe to put me maybe do but
you're the product right but but if you
if you can keep this
this year your most sensitive
information within your Citadel then
maybe there's another business model
namely maybe the Citadel can stand as
the as the intermediary between you and
the merchants in which you'd actually
like to buy things the merchants would
like to sell things to you so if the
Citadel can act as an honest middlemen
without exploiting you working for you
maybe there's a business model for that
the only problem is it stands in total
opposition to the current surveillance
advertising model based on data centers
centralized now the thing that we have
going for us is physics namely once we
can plug in let's see we do this I
should have done it before but maybe
it's not too late is there a electrical
plug here someplace
anybody no yes there is I see
electricity okay my Citadel is about to
go down now we plug it in there we go
and we have electricity okay so that is
the challenge is is is can we pay for
the the the Citadel's right the software
for the Citadel's in terms of
maintenance and upgrading right based on
this kind of model of serving as an
intermediary between the family and
these merchants out there we don't know
there's some people in Germany
interested in it and who knows certainly
the investors in Silicon Valley don't
seem to be very interested in funding
this
of thing but we have physics on our side
in the sense that that that because of
the hollow glasses right and the
intelligent systems the computation
needs to be here and not in the data
center there's not enough computation
than the data center to do the
intelligent systems and also there's not
enough that the latencies are too long
to support the hollow glasses so it's
some there's a forcing function for this
to happen and we don't know how it's
going to play out in terms of the
economics here whether anybody will leap
into this or not and it raises another
question who has access to this
information now that we concentrated it
it's it's wonderful thing the Citadel
can do a much better job of providing
recommendations to the merchants out
there it knows all about you right it's
even better than what Facebook and
Google can do now because Facebook
doesn't know what Google knows Google
doesn't know what Facebook knows right
but the Citadel's got it all so that
raises the issue of the backdoors and
there's this thing with a wonderful name
that these security guys came up for
nyborg it stands for nothing is beyond
our reach
and they mean it
so it's mandatory back doors in which
they require a different public key in
each device a packet that derives of the
internet that decrypts using the crypts
using the public key is a bootloader for
a difficult to detect virtual machine
that takes over your machine takes over
your phone while you're talking on the
phone this is enforced by registering
the devices and manufacturers so it your
your phone won't connect to the public
internet unless it can so be so be taken
over and the device requires that any
device the required stick that connects
to it can also be taken over now this is
really something this will take some
infrastructure but this is the same kind
of infrastructure that we currently use
for our nuclear command and control
system so it indeed can be built and it
can be built securely because they
thought this through for example you
might say ah there'll be a bug in the
virtual machine that they install on my
phone yeah they think we know that as
soon as we find that bug we'll take your
phone over again using this very same
means and put in the patched VM so this
is a very very secure way of doing
things so you said I'd say well maybe
there's a workaround so what I would
work around here's a workaround that's
actually been used in practice by the
hackers and that is you have the phone
on the left okay it's on the public
internet so it is then taken over and
the phone on the right okay is air gap
it's never been on the internet you put
them face-to-face
you plug up the the microphone right and
the Speaker of the
laughs you're talking the one on the
right and then you use a encrypted
communication between the two this has
actually been done so one of the
security forces do about that well they
take it over the one on the left right
one of the things they've done is they
they they try to subtly disrupt the one
on the right so you'll give up and go
back to using the one on the left and
the other thing they can do is they can
just you know but since they've totally
taken over the one on the Left I can
detect it you're doing that and just cut
off communication with the one on the
right so that's kind of a spy versus spy
kind of thing but they have all the
advantage because they totally taken
over completely taken over the one on
the left
okay so now Bohr is an inconvenient
truth to use famous words I missed Val
Gore it's an inconvenient truth for two
camps the upstream camp and the
downstream yep the upstream camp this is
the e FF the ACLU and some
cryptographers right and they claim the
problem Nyborg is the hackers can get in
or the foreign intelligence agencies can
get in and it's pretty clear that that's
not the case because no country is going
to deploy this we're not going to deploy
it okay if there's any chance that the
foreign intelligence agency can get in
and hack this thing right just like we
don't we try as best we can just like we
don't deploy a nuclear command and
control system with the thought that
important intelligence agency can get in
so they're good engineering ways to deal
with that for example what you do on
each one of these devices on the private
key you have to hold the private key is
you split it into five parts you have
five nuclear you have five different
command centers right so you need five
you need three you need three Ben
Arnold's to subvert one phone that's
pretty good it's hard to get three
Benedict Arnold generals out of one
heart out of some opposing army then
downstream the question is what does the
government do when it gets the
information from these flat back doors
there are huge problems there you they
can be used for blackmail it can be used
for political intimidation it can be
used for corruption
for example J Edgar Hoover use this
backdoor information by intercepting the
calls between J robert Oppenheimer and
his lawyer against him in trial for
Oppenheimer security clearance so
there's a denial on both sides on the
upstream side the e FF the ACLU and some
cryptographers wanna claim that they
can't do it right the problem is that
they can't do it the people on the
downstream side the J edgar Hoover's and
the Jane commis say that it's not so bad
that we really want to catch these child
pornographers right and these terrorists
but the problem is that if we actually
put mandatory backdoors into our hollow
glasses where they can see and hear
everything that we see here and do we
don't know what a civilization can
survive that level of surveillance or
not so we have an interesting situation
where we an inconvenient truth and
currently we have two camps and both
sides both camps are in denial the FF
and ACLU camp are in denial that they
can do it and the J edgar Hoover's and
Jane commis are in denial that it could
be very very bad and that's where we
currently stand so
the challenge is to create is to use
these holy losses for scalable
intelligent systems for communities for
activities for spirituality and the only
thing standing between us that and where
we are now is immense complexity in
terms of a project this is not going to
be cheap this is Manhattan a scale
funding now it can be distributed you
can get you know the holy glasses can
kind of be split off some and the actor
many cores can be split off some okay
but the heart of the thing is going to
be really difficult the best
inconsistency robust ontology that
matrix the natural language stuff and
colleagues dan Flickinger and all of
Emily then Emily vendor and then kopeck
and the experiences the stuff being done
at UC Santa Cruz on making interactive
experiences and then putting all that
inside the Citadel's that is really
something that is one hell of an
enormous challenge and we don't know
whether the West can do it or not you
might think that since the Germans
discovered nuclear fission and they had
all the scientists that they would have
the huge advantage they had the
scientific base they had the industrial
establishment surely they would be the
ones to do the bomb first but they
didn't we have the scientific base we
have the engineering talent do we have
the will and the organization to do it
we don't
does the West have the dvv organization
and the ability to mount a project to do
it and we don't know it's aspected that
there's at least one other place can and
that's China however this is going to
have consequences how this plays out
it's going to have real consequences
thank you very much
[Applause]